[Musique]
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
nagui est un animateur demandé à la tête
de trois émission quotidienne sur france
2 et france inter
l'animateur de 58 ans enchaîne il faut
que tu t'en vas un tout petit peu plus
s'il enregistre par avance ses jeu tout
le monde veut prendre sa place et
n'oubliez pas les paroles
il est chaque jour en direct à la radio
dans la bande originale tu reviens à ce
micro quand tu veux un agenda bien
rempli et un porte-monnaie qu'il est
aussi car selon le magazine capital
nagui serait également un homme
d'affaires avisé merci en tout cas que
c'est notamment grâce à la vente de sa
société air productions a banni jay que
l'animateur aurait touché le pactole une
négociation au cours de laquelle il
aurait obtenu 5% des parts du groupe
banijay une participation estimée à 20
millions d'euros à l'achat sans compter
que chaque année nagui toucherait entre
750 mille euros et un million d'euros de
salaire pour ses émissions sur france
télévisions et 150000 euros pour la
radio bref de quoi voir venir
je suis toujours étonné en france et à
côté délation de montrer du doigt ceux
qui réussissent et qu'il y ait de
l'argent surtout que magee on l'a dit la
3 quotidienne par jour donc 2 sur france
2 qui cartonne que ce soit le béa enfin
un peu moins le midi mais surtout le
soir et vous voulez que je vous dise
benjamin les deux voix rauque est un
grand animateur qui était un ancien
élève à toi qui as anciennement gagner
du pognon en plus sur vous avez souvent
parler d'argent souvent donné les
salaires mirobolants à l'époque de tf1
alors deux parenthèses les salaires que
j'ai annoncée était la moyenne des
années heures de la chaîne bien sûr je
vais le redire pour que les jeux soient
très claires sur tf1 il ya encore dix
ans on est en été on était en factures
par an salers et de la facture n'était
pays trente mille euros par prime time
par exemple et vous avez l'honnêteté de
le dire mais voilà vous animez un contre
sens avec quatre émissions par jour etc
mais ce que je fais 30000 euros un oui
mais ce que je peux vous dire sur nagui
c'est que c'est beaucoup plus que les
chiffres qui sont annoncés par capitale
ils craignent beaucoup plus mon sens
quasi matters et producteur ca s'élève à
beaucoup plus d'un million d'euros par
an pour nagui ah oui on serait plutôt
dire combien alors alors je vais pas le
chiffre exact upa dans ses relevés de
compte mais ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que un million c'est pas possible
parce que si on cumule des salaires qui
est là sur france 2 et sur france inter
si on peut en cumul les dividendes qui
touche grâce au groupe banijay et toutes
ces heures crétois les choix qu'il a
vendu 80 % de sa boîte en aban et gedo
qui a pas de dividende
pour cela il à 5,5 force il a cinq
d'argent par la peine pour ça pèse 5 %
benji faille et moi exagérée déjà
attention cheryl out out à torse et qui
sait ce qui t'expliquent le bilan là
elle est très bien fait il sépare les
choses ils ont expliqué que c'était 751
millions pour l'animation est bannie gc
au dessus c'est 20 millions d'euros ce
héros
donc il faut effectivement tout ça voilà
et je pense que ça doit être parents tu
penses à n'être pas 20 millions par an
je pense qu'il est il est pas mal oui et
vous avez vous avez des parts de bagages
et ou non malheureusement je n'ai pas
négocié sa méchante rien ne dit que
j'étais con non non j'ai pas j'ai pas de
perdants ben ali g mais bannis diané
pardon mais c'est ça alors je précise
quand même que ça c'était avant le
rachat de 2d boy plus longtemps peiné
déjà racheté des vols c'est le premier
groupe mondial 1 avec plus de 3
milliards de chiffre d'affaires c'est
colossal
mais il a fait ça fait ça fait pour
l'instant pas mal de pertes pour
l'instant mais ça va changer
mécénat parce qu'ils gagnent beaucoup
d'argent qu'on doit le dénoncer il
rapporte aussi beaucoup d'argent c'est
un animateur qui fait des programmes qui
cartonne sur france télé donc moi je
trouve pas ça bien de pointer du doigt à
chaque fois ce qui gagne des sous le dv
bien sûr je suis totalement d'accord
avec avec sacha mais on l'a pas
véritablement dénoncé dans la mesure où
il en parle de façon très tranquille
dans les interviews que j'ai lu de lui
où il disait qu effectivement n'était
pas loin du million d'euros par an ici
il est très à l'aise avec ça et puis
c'est le roi de la négo on va pas on va
pas le flageller parce qu'il a très bien
négocié ses contrats france télé disait
de lui qu en tout cas à l'heure où ils
émettaient quand il avait fait
l'interview
nagui rapportait beaucoup plus d'argent
que eux n'en dépensait pour la voir donc
moi je crois qu il est il est à un
carrefour de plus belle dès 9 heures
avec la pub pour te faire péter c'est
vrai qu'il n'aurait jamais il n'aurait
jamais marché s'ils n'avaient pas talent
donc c'est une vraie success story à la
française et pour tous les jeunes qui
veulent se réaliser qu'ils iront un jour
je veux être nagui non malabar vous vous
êtes vous avez vendu combien votre boîte
vous avez vous avez une boîte alors moi
je les vends du bst avant moi je n'ai
pas bien vendus dont je vous disais pas
une fable papa mais avant de juger pas
bien vendu
vous avez d'autres questions à la con
comme ça on peut avancer
moi j'étais chez ma décision au bon
moment voilà c'était alors vous la
donner le chiffre exact banon mais on
les a beaucoup moins on est à moins de
toku moins de 5 millions d'euros un coût
moins beaucoup moins mais il faut plus
de 2 millions plus 2 millions mais non
ces voix là attendez parce qu'après
quand vous vendez votre société vous
mettez dans l'axé tous vos revenus et
quand vous vendez la boîte bouger plus
d'argent par ailleurs appelé donc
l'argent que vous récupérez c'est après
après la plus donc trois millions et
demi quoi donc mais je voudrais pas
répondu en revanche et après le bol
c'est qu'il faut il faut que cela est
faux que la boîte marche ça ne marche
pas c'est une catastrophe
et dans mon cas but je suis très très
bon en affaires et en gestion de la
boîte ne marchais pas c'est vrai ce que
je veux dire
voilà donc ce n'était pas très beau mais
l'opération que gagner beaucoup d'argent
avant c'était votre million et demi
qu'on peut féliciter c'est stéphane
courbit quand même la tête de tout ça et
bien su avoir le flair
d'autant qu'au début manager comme je
voulais 10 et c'était pas c'était très
compliqué maintenant c'est l'animé a
tancé numéro un mondiale en venant
coiffer oui rachel wood et que vous
pouvez les shows peut-être un peu
choquant
avec le show bercy le modem avec
l'argent quand même tout le monde parle
d'argent de dévoiler l'argent de calais
nous on se trouve à des maths arrivera
jamais bon ben ça m'arrivera c'est ce
sont des belles réussites je vous
reconnais que dans capital est toujours
un côté de montrer du doigt ému ce qu'il
a fait ce qu'il a gagné combien les
vignes etc
moi je rappelle une chose mais je vais
quand même défendez petits camarades
d'abord ils font travailler un nombre de
gens est considérable c'est des fiches
de paye à la fin du mois c'est des réals
et des maquilleurs c'est des coiffeurs
et des décorateurs cd voilà donc c'est
très important que ces gens là
fonctionne parce que grâce à eux
d'autres gens au travail et vous avez il
ya un proverbe qui il va se vérifier
très bientôt c'est que quand les gros
maigrissent sont maîtres qui meurt on
devrait souhaiter que tout le monde
gagne de l'argent et qu'on puisse faire
travailler le plus de gens possible à la
main
je vais défendre je vais ramasser
je vais je vais je vais défendre ça
parce que l'effectif
finalement c'est un peu agaçante montré
des vertus auxquelles les gens qui
laissa looking de l'argent parce que
c'est pas de ça le king d'argent
n'aurait pas dit qu'il irait aussi de
l'argent des salaires voilà